Italy has set another record for the
most deaths from coronavirus in a single
day nearly 1,000 people have died in the
past 24 hours
that brings the total death toll to more
than 9,000 that's the highest number of
any country and health officials say the
worst may be yet to come hospital wards
are still full although doctors say the
number of patients is now steadying
contagion rates appear to be slowing as
well giving hope that the strict social
controls in effect may be working but
the lockdown is hitting the Italian
economy hard churches and charities are
struggling to care for people in need of
basic supplies are the spring and
journalists Seema Gupta she's following
the situation from Rome Seema first of
course just let's talk about that that
shocking number nearly 1000 people dead
in just 24 hours of is there a sense
that Italy is is now approaching perhaps
the peak of this crisis well Carl what
the officials are telling us is that
Italy is not near the peak it is not in
the declining phase in fact we heard
from the representatives of Italy's
National Health Institute and they say
the only thing they can point out in
terms of a slight light at the end of
this dark dark tunnel is that the curve
of contagion appears to be slightly
flattening especially since the 20th of
March and they believe that that is a
good sign now the the president of the
Lombardy region that's the hardest-hit
region that saw some 50% of those deaths
that we saw in that one day close to a
thousand that massive figure he said
that the region may see a decline in the
next few days it's hard to understand
how these figures work when you see such
massive numbers but what's clear as well
as the members of the Institute of
national health have told us it's
inevitable that the lockdown period at
least will be extended beyond their
third April date that was set earlier in
this crisis we've seen these uplifting
videos of Italians singing from their
balconies
what is it like there now I mean how
difficult is it to keep that
sort of spirit going in Italy well
called those flash mobs seem to have
stops I mean just dealing with these
depressing figures it's just hard to
grasp the immense nature of this tragedy
you're talking about figures that could
be a small village an entire village
being obliterated just in the space of
24 hours it's absolutely heartbreaking I
think some Italians maybe even many
Italians found some solace perhaps on
Friday when we saw Pope Francis go to
Saint Peter's Square and give this
prayer to help those that are suffering
and to pray for an end to this pandemic
it was very dramatic those images of
rain pouring on what was an empty st.
Peter's Square and the Pope Francis
standing in the middle are praying for
this at the same time it's those health
care workers that I in the front line
fighting this battle we know so far 46
doctors have died as a result of kovat
19 and more than 6,000 health care
workers are infected they are the ones
of course on the front lines of the
pandemic Seema Gupta for us in Rome
thank you for your pouring when it comes
to social distancing the Pope is leading
by example just a few scattered visitors
follow the pontiff's prayer service from
afar it's st. Peter's Square he compares
the pandemic to a storm that has hit
almost the entire globe city man for
weeks now it has been evening thick
darkness has gathered over our squares
our streets and our cities we feel it in
the air we notice in people's gestures
their glances give them away we find
ourselves afraid and lost in poverty is
morality I fear that the Pope himself
likely shares five cases of covered 19
have been diagnosed in the Vatican so
far one of them reportedly inside the
papal residency
Tiamo resi quanto realize that we are on
the same boat all of us fragile and
disoriented but at the same time
important and needed all of us called to
row together each of us having to
comfort the other on this boat we are
all together so West abarca te amo duty
duty after his address Francis went on
to perform the world premiere he
delivered the oak be at or be blessing
that is usually saved for Holi
ceremonies Easter and Christmas
it is the blessing to the city and the
world even though this time almost no
one was there to receive it in person
you